[Music]
okay let's check out the uh nile miami
thing so go to his instagram real fast
just scroll down don't click that most
recent one so yeah this is a bunch of
[ __ ] so yeah maybe start at that one and
we can just get some content something
huge is coming and it's not mine
and it's jack harlow
oh man what does that one say that one
says um getting my dick sucked in the
pool wow
bro whoa that says get ready for it
something insane is about to happen
right okay he's building this up pretty
hard he's he's posting just gifs there's
no music yeah but like what okay what
does that say follow me everywhere and
then he just links his other ones okay
so you're like what the [ __ ] is gonna
happen the one show is about to premiere
so this guy dude is not has nothing to
do with the one anymore yeah he doesn't
own it yeah he still owes people money
for it probably yeah but someone else
owns it the guy who [ __ ] started
fashionova owns it now yeah but he's
still hanging onto this thing like the
name of it
trying to like kind of leach whatever
attention he can off of it yeah
i'm sorry i'm just like really drawn
into the stock nature of these graphics
yeah
yeah
yeah it kind of perplexes me like who
even makes these for him
you won't believe it as the next one so
this is just a series of instagram gifs
that he's posting building up to
something he said something insane is
about to happen yeah and you're gonna
say something are you gonna say insane
in 2022 that's a [ __ ] high bar yeah
trump podcasted with the boys yeah yeah
yeah you got a [ __ ] and what does
this mean it's already tomorrow what
does that mean does that mean like it's
coming tomorrow or like today is
tomorrow wake up it's already tomorrow
he's just in australia
producer artist
visionary oh this dude is crazy he's
back
whoa
damn
he said he was like [ __ ] he said
[ __ ]
okay
so what is it
[Music]
what okay that's the third shot that's
what i'm saying yeah he seems to think
that him getting naked and footage of
his ding-dong is gonna promote whatever
this is
get ready for my hog i'm gonna make a
bold claim here all right two things one
this is kind of insane objectively what
he's doing is insane yeah you're right
yeah yeah he used that pretty accurately
he is living up to that part yeah i'll
give him credit there too
the world took john mcafee from us and
maybe this is the universe replacing him
yeah i'm gonna go with
1.0 because no one could ever be john
mcafee yeah but okay yeah i mean yeah
this guy's just showing his dick john
mcafee threatened to eat his own dick
and i think john mcafee
did murder yeah yeah he did all right
next no i want to see the rest of this
oh yeah sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
starting a travel show
oh
sweet man no but that it's not a show
because it's yeah this is the thing he's
promoting the one truth network which i
think has something to do with crypto or
nfts or it's gated in some way oh he's
saying prepare to travel oh maybe like
you buy a thing and then you can go
travel with it i think that's that was
the impression that i got initially but
why would i want to right like that
look at this guy's like whipping his
dick out on the airport i don't want to
like yeah that [ __ ] yeah yeah get on the
no fly yeah exactly it's like now
they're [ __ ] relax
[Music]
something huge what is the yeah what's
the label huge ass that's the deathly
hallows it's definitely a rip of the
deathly hallows yeah no but it's the one
truth network dude is the deathly
hallows a harry potter book yeah yeah
was that the most recent one that he
posted yeah the last video we watched is
the most recent if this is a travel
series i'm watching the [ __ ] out of it i
mean look at that look at the website
for this yeah so this is what it says on
the website there is only one nile miami
the one to live to watch to feel to love
to hate to play to you
okay the one will open his inner self on
daily and never before seen life
vignettes with the intent to be funny
thought provoking
raw and uplifting
dare to enter the one world and be
forever engaged to the one truth network
he really is starting a cult this is a
[ __ ] cult yeah so now he did a house
called the one and now he's claiming he
is the one yeah this is blowing my mind
this is actually awesome you know why he
won't have to pay a single person back
your honor my client is clinically
insane he actually
i think he actually is i think it's a
mixture of drugs he clearly like in that
producer michael video that they toured
the one he's clearly on cocaine at least
how would you know because he's like
standing there like
sniffing like
it's obvious is it i don't know i try to
play up like i have a cocaine a day oh
no no no
you said it you said it
not every episode because you were doing
cocaine right
we're just trying to get you to slip
it's just me in the audience just trying
to get you to admit okay fine i have
bags and bags of cocaine in my house
[Laughter]
i do it with nile sometimes yeah there
we go that's what we're looking for dude